In the previous lesson,
we built a method for
escaping the characters in
the parameters of our URL,
to make sure that none of
the characters were unsafe ASCII.
Now, our method worked, but Apple
actually provides a set of classes that
we can use to accomplish
the exact same thing.
The first of these classes that we're
going to talk about is NSURLComponents.
NSURLComponents is a class
designed to help us
build URLs in a piecewise fashion.
That is to say that a URL can be built
from individual pieces or components.
If we look at URLs more closely we
can start to see some of these common
components.
Here's a URL for
a web page that has information about
Udacity's nano degree programs.
We can actually omit the www portion.
It isn't required, and
we can focus on the rest.
The first part of the URL
called the scheme
specifies the protocol that we're using.
In this case,
the scheme we're using is https.
Next, the part many refer to as
the website name, here it's udacity.com,
is called the host name,
or host for short.
The host is used to determine
the location of the server.
The final part of this
URL is called the path.
It specifies the location on the server
where the resource that we want
is located.
In this case, we want the resource
located at the path nanodegree.
And like we said before, the resource
at this location is a webpage that has
information about Udacity's
nano degree programs.
Using NSURL components, we can create
this URL in just a few lines of code.
And you can see here in this code
example that I've had to use these slash
character in the path, that is required,
so it may not look the exact same on
the previous screen that we saw, but
you'll need to provide the slash here.
But what about a more complex URL like
the ones we'll be using in FlickFinder?
Here's another example.
This URL uses the Flickr APIs
flickr.photos.search method.
And just so you know,
I've omitted some of the parameters in
this particular example for brevity.
We can go ahead and label the scheme,
the host and the path,
but what do we call everything else?
Well the question mark separates the
path from the next component in this URL
that's called the query.
The query is composed of name
value pairs that a server can
use to determine its response.
You'll notice that each pair
is separated by an ampersand.
To add the query component to
a URL using NSURLComponents,
we need to introduce a new
class called NSURLQueryItem.
The NSURLQueryItem represents a single
name value pair in the query component
of a URL.
To create an NSURLQueryItem
is pretty straightforward.
We just need to specify the name and
the value.
Then, NSURLComponents has
a property called queryItems,
which is an array of NSURLQueryItem.
So we can just add any queryItems
that we make to this array.
In code,
it might look something like this.
If we go over here we might
see the resulting URL.
And I know this might seem like
a lot of work just to create a URL.
But the big trade off is that NSURL
components takes care of insuring that
our URLs are properly escaped and
only contains safe ASCII characters.
And that's a nice reinsurance for us.
Let's take a look at one final example.
This URL is taken from Matt Thompson's
post on NSURL components on NSHipster.
I posted a link to the article
in the instructor notes.
Now, on first glance this
URL is a lot to take in, but
it just contains some extra
optional components of the URL.
They're already labeled here and
if you're interested I encourage you
to check out the article to learn more.